Africa is rising today half of its
population is under the age of 20 by the
end of the century its population is
expected to quadruple much of
sub-saharan Africa has seen rapid
economic growth and a burgeoning middle
class so what does this all mean foreign
investors are seeing huge potential in
Africa
yes natural resources are still a hot
commodity like the cobalt used in
rechargeable batteries to run all our
gadgets but they're now looking at new
industries like clean energy
construction banking and information
technology and they're targeting the
rising middle class that is now expanded
to about a third of Africans more local
entrepreneurs are launching startups in
Africa which is now home to a number of
the world's fastest growing economies
and major companies are taking part
including Toyota China National Offshore
Oil Company Bharti Airtel L'Oreal and
IBM in 2014 foreign investments were
predicted to reach a record high of 80
billion dollars almost six times as much
as that invested just a decade earlier
we see a lot of economic potential in
the region for 2015 so here's our list
of environmental heroes you should know
about